so if i was to put my compass down at
work i've got that app on my phone where
it shows me the direction
yeah yeah of course yeah when you pray
no there's a set prayer there's like
five daily set prayers
which i do at set times like sunrise
uh lunchtime afternoon evening and night
time
fajr maghrib they're the five daily
prayers
you know what i'm i couldn't be any
other way i couldn't live
any other way now now i found islam i
couldn't i couldn't
drift and wander a little bit but i
couldn't be any i couldn't live another
life
because i would just break i just i just
i just couldn't function
because the inner peace that i get from
knowing my god and my creator
and worshiping my god in my career the
way he's legislated
it just it just fulfills me completely
all the mistakes that i make in my life
that fulfills me
i make mistakes brother on a daily on a
daily
and i say things and i do things and
this and that but the peace that i have
knowing that i that i've found
islam and found allah is it's
uncomparable to drugs
drink women this this this it's just
nothing compares
nothing i've done my fair share of
pioneer
when i was younger i was done my fair
share i've put more pills than i care to
mention
you know but nothing makes me
happier than just praying or knowing or
just knowing daily that i'm a muslim
that's it yeah
nothing makes me happy to laugh at
working and in the gym and in the other
places but when it comes down to it
yeah that's how i feel inside that's my
that's my
belief we call it in arabic iman that's
mighty man
you can who's stopping you who's
stopping you
listen there's always going to be
atrocities there's always going to be
wars and it's all
and it's heartbreaking and you feel it i
feel it anyone with any compassion
feels it but that's not the thought of
the religion there's no religion it says
go and kill the baby or go and kill the
innocent person
you know what let me explain to this
because people say this all the time if
there was a god why is there death why
is there cancer why is there war
right but imagine life is a massive big
screen
with a with a film on it now screens are
made of pixels aren't they
imagine that we are so small our little
brain our little life
we are so small our comprehension is
that we are looking at one pixel
but god he's standing back as if it were
and he can see
the whole picture the whole story he he
created it he knows the past present and
future
because he created time and everything
in it so we only have an understanding
there's things that we don't know about
our own
finger or our own life you know what i
mean so
how do we expect to understand them
intricacies it's not possible
so i just know that there's a bigger
plan and i trust the plan even if i died
even if i
god forbid they said you've got a
terminal illness you're gonna die in six
weeks i've got kids
i don't want to leave my kids but that's
god's plan and i trust god's plan
you know alhamdulillah i trust it